sur les premières mesures qui semblent
être annoncé j'ai le sentiment qu'on va
être dans le traditionnel en même temps
c'est à dire vraisemblablement dans
l'immobilisme à france est devenue
d'ailleurs le premier pays d'europe de
demandes d'asile bien avant tous les
autres pays européens ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya une vraie attraction social
ensuite sur sur ce délai de carence de
trois mois 90 % des déboutés du droit
d'asile ne sont jamais raccompagné aux
frontières jamais donc qui a délai de
carence de 15 jours de trois semaines ou
de trois mois je pense que ça ne
changera rien d'abord le gouvernement de
monsieur mac on commence par appliquer
la loi et à raccompagner aux frontières
les gens qui n'ont qui sont en situation
illégale en france avait la seule mesure
en deux ans qui étaient prises en
matière d'immigration par monsieur
macron c'est d'élargir les possibilités
du regroupement familial c'est la seule
mesure concrète depuis deux ans et demi
il ya une mesure concrète élargir les
possibilités du regroupement familial
aux collatéraux
donc avant qu'ils aient une application
tant mieux s'il le fait et nous
soutiendrons simplement
permettez moi d'en douter très largement
l'aide médicale d'état qu'on voudrait
transformer en aide médicale d'urgence
c'est-à-dire uniquement pour les cas
d'urgence
et pour lutter contre les grandes
endémies là on est sur un puits sans
fond plus d'un milliard d'euros sur sur
l'aim
pourquoi
personne qui en situation illégale en
france bénéficierait d'une protection
sociale moins cher que quelqu'un qui
travaille au quotidien et qui en
situation légale et nous sommes toujours
favorables à une politique globale des
quotas là nous sommes uniquement sur le
secteur économique
c'est à dire c'est 10 à 15% à peu près
puisque ça va concerner environ trente
mille trente mille personnes sur 260
milles titre de séjour qui ont été
acceptés cette année c'est à dire on
doit être à 14 % d'augmentation par
rapport à l'année dernière donc on a une
explosion de ce côté là et donc les
quotas tels qu'ils veulent les mettre en
place et non pas tel que nous nous
souhaitons c'est uniquement sur le
secteur économique c'est à dire ça va
concerner 10 % des titres de séjour on
demande au président de la république
qu'il assume ses responsabilités et je
ne peux pas je ne peux pas accepter sont
pas je ne peux pas accepter l'idée qu'il
dise que le voile dans l'espace public
ça n'est pas son affaire
c'est son affaire